young guys and girls will message and
say I'm 13 and I love your podcast what
the Fantastic you are in a growth period
that is unbelievable and the people that
you're getting exposed to I wish I'd had
access to at 13 what should I do if I
want to improve myself what books should
I read what practices should I do I
don't mean to be patronizing but just go
outside and live life there is so much
loow hanging fruit from knowing what
it's like to have an argument with your
friend and having to cycle home with a
flat tire there is so many life
experiences that I think you will gain
massive amounts huge huge amounts of
benefit from over and above a 2d lesson
so me and my friend George have this
conception of a 2d lessons and 3D
lessons a 2d lesson would be reading
about Warren Buffett's wealth through an
autobiography or watching it a 3D lesson
would be hanging out with Warren Buffett
at his house for an afternoon no matter
how immersive we try and make learning
you can't forget them they're so
visceral and in a world where most of
our time an increasing proportion of our
time is spent online inperson 3D lessons
become more and more and more powerful